BoBonsoir à tous. On ne peut pas
vovous le faire entendre, faire
enentendre cette blague de
MoMonsieur Legault, dit-il,
mamauvaise blague parce qu'elle
n'n'est pas audible et elle état
hohors micro mais tout le monde
l'l'a entendu. Je vous donne le
cocontexte, Monsieur Pierre Arcd
sese lève pour poser une questin
etet Monsieur Legault le regarde
etet il dit : il n'est pas mort,
lului? Et cela a créé une vive
réréaction du côté des libéraux.
OnOn va écouter des réactions de
MoMonsieur Pierre Arcand et
MoMonsieur Legault ensuite.
PIPIERRE ARCAND, député, PLQ
MoMont-Royal-Outremont
- - Ça sert à quoi, tout ce qu'n
a a fait, si on est traité comme
çaça, de la façon dont il m'a
trtraité? Alors, je voulais juse
vovous dire simplement que
jeje suis ébranlé très fortemen.
EtEt aujourd'hui, je peux
sisimplement vous dire qu'il
n'n'était pas digne d'être premr
miministre. Même si j'accepte
leles excuses, ça demeure
papas moins que je pense que les
QuQuébécois doivent prendre not,
unun moment donné, qu'il y a
unune limite à l'arrogance.
JeJe comprends qu'il y a une joe
paparlementaire qui doit se fai,
mamais un moment donné, là, pour
ememployer une expression, c'est
unun coup en bas de la ceinture!
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Pierre Arcand puis moi,
onon se connaît, on se voit,
chchez lui, chez moi.
JeJe l'apprécie beaucoup.
PuPuis, je trouve que Dominique
AnAnglade l'utilise pas assez,
ququ'elle lui donne pas
asassez de questions à poser,
pupuis c'est assez spécial
paparce que, ce matin, quand
j'j'ai vu qu'il se levait enfin,
jeje me suis dit : Bien, enfin!
IlIl est pas mort, on l'utilise
enenfin! Dononc, c'était positif
àà l'égard de Pierre.
BoBon, moins à l'égard peut-être
dede Dominique, mais c'était
unune mauvaise blague,
çaça a été mal perçu, puis
jeje me suis tout de suite excu.
- - Est-ce que c'était
dede l'arrogance? Est-ce que
c'c'était une insulte?
- - Bien non, bien non, bien no,
c'c'était une mauvaise blague.
- - Et d'ailleurs, c'est par
TwTwitter qu'il a prononcé tout
cecela. Quand vous aurez agité?
MaMauvaise blague isolée?
- - Bien, l'arrogance, je veux
didire c'est un trait de
cacaractère, donc on ne parle ps
d'd'un trait de caractère s'il y
a a pas eu d'autres démonstratis
dede la chose dans le passé. Jee
pepense pas qu'on serait en tran
dede se poser la question s'il y
avavait pas eu d'autres choses
dadans la façon dont le premier
miministre se comporte à
l'l'Assemblée nationale et
aiailleurs. Ça me fait un peu
pepenser aussi à Yves-François
BlBlanchet durant la dernière
cacampagne électorale. C'était e
acaccumulation d'anecdotes et de
chchoses qui ne passaient pas et
ququi faisait en sorte qu'on se
mimit utiliser ce mot. C'est
susurtout le premier ministre
coconcentre les pouvoirs à
l'l'Assemblée nationale depuis
lolongtemps avec la mesure sur
l'l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui
fafait en sorte qu'il y a beaucp
dede concentration de pouvoir à
l'l'Assemblée nationale. Ça done
unun gouvernement qui a une très
foforte majorité et s'assoit sur
seses lauriers. Ce n'est pas la
prpremière fois qu'il a des
cocommentaires déplacés. Si on
ararrive à ce mot d'arrogance,
c'c'est à cause de tout ce
cocontexte
- - effectivement, je veux dire
dedepuis un bout de temps, on ne
pepeut pas critiquer gouvernemet
etet même quand on parle de chos
cocomme le 3e lien qui est très
cocontestable, le gouvernement t
: : non, et ce qui n'en veulent
papas, vous n'êtes pas... c'est
pepeut-être une mauvaise blague.
PiPierre Arcand ne mérite pas ç,
ilil a été le chef intérimaire e
soson parti. C'est peut-être la
pipire job. Mais Monsieur Legaut
enen essayant de s'excuser c'est
cacalé encore plus. Il a dit :
c'c'est mon ami, je vais veiller
chchez eux des fois. On ne dit s
dedes choses comme ça quand on
paparle d'un ami, pas dans les
gegens que je fréquente du moins
- - qu'est-ce que ça révèle? - n
mamanque de sensibilité de la pt
dudu premier ministre. Il a été
trtrès maltraité. J'ai été un de
ceceux qu'il a défendus. Souven-
vovous de l'épisode de Monsieur
ArArcand qui avait eu le malheur
d'd'aller dans le sud. On s'est
mimis à taper sur lui. - Lui avt
mmême enlevé ses responsabilité.
- - On sent que Monsieur Arcand,
çaça a réveillé ses blessures.Ça
nene pouvait pas être autrement.
DeDe dire : est-ce qu'il est mo?
EtEt grand manque de sensibilité
dede Monsieur Legault. Le
gogouvernement du Québec pendant
unun an et demi à gouverner sans
opopposition. Il y avait une
esespèce de docilité incroyable.
IlIl faut que le gouvernement
acaccepte qu'il y a de
l'l'opposition. Mais c'est très
ininsensible d'avoir 10 à Pierre
ArArcand. - Est-ce qu'il n'y a s
icici et là un manque de respect
enenvers l'opposition et enverse
rrôle de l'opposition?
- - Ils se sont des habitués de
l'l'opposition. Il y avait des
grgrandes messes quotidiennes et
totous les Québécois disaient o.
IlIls se sont habitués à ça.
- - Et le personnel politique sr
TwTwitter. Cette phénomène
rerelativement nouveau, ils
atattaquent certains des élus de
l'l'opposition ils vont rire de
susur Twitter. Il y a une
agagressivité convoyait moins en
pupublic sur les réseaux sociau.
- - Le soir de l'élection
papartielle de Marie-Victorin,
MoMonsieur Jolin-Barette a dit :
mamaintenant : l'opposition doit
cocomprendre qu'elle doit arrêtr
dede faire la partisannerie. Ily
avavait 65 % des gens qui avaiet
vovoté contre le parti au pouvo.
UnUn moment donné, c'est toujous
lala faute des autres, en contiu
etet on n'a pas besoin de changr
jajamais. C'est un peu... c'estn
pepeu frustrant et c'est peut-êe
ququelque chose qui va nuire à a
CACAQ au moment des élections. n
momoment donné, quand les gens e
didisent : le gouvernement va êe
trtrop fort, je pense qu'on va
leleur envoyer une forte
opopposition, quand Monsieur
LeLegault dit : je vais peut-ête
avavoir sans siège et ça ne me
dédérange pas. Vous allez gagner
etet réformer le mode de scrutin
vovous aide et vous n'êtes pas.e
nene veux pas partir Christian -
dedessus. - Mais Émilie, ce n'et
papas quand on est très fort, ts
pupuissant qu'on doit être encoe
plplus respectueux envers des
opoppositions qui en arrachent :
lele parti libéral, ce n'est pas
unune très bonne période. Est-ce
ququ'on a besoin d'insister à ce
popoint.
- - C'est sûr que dans l'opinion
pupublique, pour le dire en ters
trtrès clairs, fessée sur des gs
àà terre, ça ne pas l'air... ça
dodonne pas de belles images. Ci
didit, il y a aussi quelque choe
d'd'intéressant par rapport à ce
ququi se passe sur Twitter parce
quque en fait, les conseillers
popolitiques, surtout au niveauu
prpremier ministre et dans
d'd'autres cabinets aussi se
seservent de la plate-forme pour
didire des choses tout au qu'ile
popourrait pas dire au nom des
élélus. Donc la ligne complètemt
flfloue entre Stéphane Gobeil
coconseillait du premier ministe
s's'exprime au nom du premier
miministre ou en son nom personl
ququand elle critique les médias
etet quand il critique les gens
opoppositions et on joue sur ce
flflou. Twitter, ça reste une
plplate-forme d'initie pas
bebeaucoup des gens du grand
pupublic ne sont pas assidus. Je
nene sais pas exactement c'est
ququoi, le but des conseillers
ququand ils font ça. Je n'ai
jajamais vu de journalistes
rereprendre des spins qui ont éé
mimis de l'avant comme ça. Mais
c'c'est juste les en fait. Et
ququand ça atteint un niveau de
lalaideur qui dépasse la norme,
s's'est repris dans le cycle de
nonouvelles et ça ne fait pas bn
paparaître le gouvernement. Je e
cocomprends pas la stratégie de
fafaire ça. Suite le projet de i
9696 et un projet de loi
imimportant. C'est la pièce qui
dedeviendra loi. J'ai préparé 2u
3 3 tableaux qui présentent les
grgrandes lignes. Ce ne sont pas
totoutes les dispositions de la
loloi 96. Le cégep, on a beaucop
paparlé : limiter la croissance
dedes places donc de réserver la
crcroissance des places aux ayas
drdroits donc ce qui en fait tot
leleur cours en anglais. Suivre.
fifinalement, c'est l'amendemen,
çaça ressemble à l'amendement ds
lilibéraux que les libéraux
avavaient voulu enlever, remette
etet c'est une autre histoire, a
vavalse-hésitation des libéraux
mamais suivre 3 cours de franças
susupplémentaires dans les 4
sesessions pour les élèves, pour
leles ayants droits, donc pour
ququ'il parle mieux français. La
lalangue du travail, prochain
tatableau et je vous le résume.a
lalangue du travail : assujettir
leles entreprises à la charte ds
plplus entreprises et encadrer s
exexigences des autres langues.
MoMonsieur Jolin-Barette veut
réréduire l'exigence du
bibilinguisme et est-ce que le
QuQuébec français dans la
coconstitution canadienne, vous
avaviez applaudi et vous trouviz
quque c'était très bon. Il y a
d'd'autres éléments mais ce sont
leles gros éléments. Tour de
tatable, je commence avec vous,
ChChristian. Il y a eu des déba.
LeLes libéraux, ce n'était pas
trtrès clair. Madame Anglade a t
: : on va voter contre
auaujourd'hui. Est-ce que c'est
unune avancée importante quand e
prprojet de loi va devenir une i
d'd'après vous pour le françaisu
QuQuébec?
- - C'est une avancée, je pense.
ChChapeau à Simon Jolin-Barette
popour le compromis qu'il a
anannoncé aujourd'hui en ce quia
trtrait au cours d'anglais ou de
frfrançais, pardon, au cégep. Ls
lilibéraux l'ont appuyé. Je troe
quque c'est respectueux de la
miminorité historique anglophon.
IlIl ne faut pas oublier que les
AnAnglos Québécois de souche sot
dedes Québécois depuis toujourst
quque l'anglais, c'est une lange
ququébécoise à ne pas mettre sur
lele même pied que le français i
dodoit être prédominant. Ça répd
àà une préoccupation également e
plplus en plus importante : les
jejeunes Anglos Québécois par
momoins français que leurs aîné.
EtEt ça commence à être documené
etet c'est inquiétant. C'est
inintéressant. Comme l'avait
rarappelé, j'avais une très bone
mémémoire, je suis très sensiblà
cece qu'ils vont faire et ce
ququ'ils vont essayer d'insérer
dadans la constitution canadien.
J'J'espère qu'ils vont parler de
lala société distincte parce que
c'c'est très important dans le
dodossier de l'intégration des
imimmigrants... aussi, il y a le
dodossier du cégep en français,
esest-ce qu'on impose la loi 101
auau cégep? Et facilement à quel
popoint il y a un mouvement très
fofort au sein de l'opinion
pupublique qui voudrait que le
gogouvernement A. Le premier
miministre Legault parce que c't
lului qui bloque ne semble pas
vovouloir le faire parce qu'il e
veveut pas faire accuser d'être
raradical et fermer le parti
lilibéral devant un dilemme. Jee
pepense pas qu'ils vont voter en
fafaveur de la loi parce que c't
trtrop un symbole pour la
clclientèles Anglos québécoises
mamais leur refus va être un peu
arartificiel parce que le point
ququi accrochait était vraiment
leles cours de français mais
glglobalement, on va voir quanda
vava être terminé mais je trouve
quque Simon Jolin-Barette a
nanavigué de façon intéressante.
- - Michel, que pensez-vous quea
vava changer
- - je pense que ça ne changera
papas grand-chose parce qu'on et
dadans une situation un peu
ététrange où les gens disent : a
loloi 101 marche pas, faisant ps
dede loi 101. Tout le projet de
loloi, c'est de resserrer les
boboulons de la loi 101. Mais s,
àà la fin du cégep, il y a plein
dede gens qui sortent du cégep t
ququi ne parle pas français, ils
onont suivi la loi 101
- - ils vont parler parce qu'ils
vovont avoir 3 gourdes plus
obobligatoires de français.
- - S'ils n'ont pas été capables
d'd'apprendre le français au
prprimaire et au secondaire,
pepensez-vous que 3 cours
obobligatoires cégep vont changr
lala chose? Peut-être la façon
dodont on enseigne le français
n'n'est pas la bonne. On fait de
lala conjugaison de verbes et on
apapprend pas commenent parler.
L'L'autre chose là-dedans, c'est
quque le gouvernement de la CAQa
trtrès peu d'antennes dans la
cocommunauté anglophone. Il ne
sasait pas quelles sont les
sysymboles, quelles sont les
chchoses qu'il ne faut pas
totoucher. Dire à un moment doné
: : va arrêter l'agrandissemente
DoDowson parce que c'est un cégp
ananglophone. Il a dit ça commea
àà l'Assemblée nationale. Ça
irirrite beaucoup de gens et mêe
lele PQ avait des gens comme Dad
papardon Dean...
ilils avaient des entrées dans a
cocommunauté anglophone. Ils
avavaient un baromètre. La CAQ
n'n'en a pas. C'est pour ça quea
fafait tant de brouhaha. Si on
avavait passé plus de temps à
exexpliquer et à vérifier quelqe
chchose on aurait peut-être eu
momoins de p problèmes.
- - Oui, démystifier quelque
chchose. Il y a les faits et
l'l'interprétation donnée mais l
fafaut avoir les canaux ouverts
popour discuter entre les
cocommunautés. Émilie, qu'est-ce
quque vous pensez de l'ensemblee
l'l'oeuvre? - En fait, je pense
ququ'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
onont résisté au projet de loi 6
etet qui le font pour des
ininquiétudes qui sont liées à a
fafaçon dont le projet va punir
dedes gens qui sont le produit u
sysystème, par exemple les
ététudiants anglophones qui n'ot
papas eu l'occasion d'apprendree
frfrançais encore parce qu'il y.
leles cours de français dans ces
tetermes anglophones ne sont pas
asassez forts, s'il y avait cete
memesure gardait qui empêche
d'd'avoir le diplôme d'études
cocollégiales, on punit des
inindividus alors que c'est le
sysystème qui est à repenser dès
lele primaire et le secondaire.
UnUne autre chose qui a suscité
bebeaucoup d'inquiétude, c'est a
ququestion des services, l'accès
auaux services dans une autre
lalangue que le français, des
seservices publics. Je me souvis
papar exemple qu'il y a beaucoup
dede personnes autochtones qui e
sosont inquiétées parce que dans
leles faits, même si les gens
dodoivent pouvoir s'ils le peuvt
ofoffrir des services en anglais
dadans les services essentiels,l
y y a beaucoup de gens qui n'ont
papas la même qualité de service
lolorsqu'il demanda être servi n
ananglais et les gens se sont ds
: : est-ce que ces gens vont ête
enencore moins bien servi quand
ilils n'ont pas le français come
lalangue matérielle par exemple
s's'ils sont autochtones?
L'L'inquiétude est là. Et commea
CACAQ est déconnectée de sa
cocommunauté, si on les rassure
papas, ça crée des mouvements de
papanique et on ne cherche pas.n
nene répond pas aux préoccupatis
dede base.
- - Oui, parce que même si
obobjectivement, les éléments du
prprojet de loi, quand on les
reregarde indépendamment, ils ne
susuffisent pas à monter une
grgrande anxiété chez beaucoup
d'd'anglophone. Il faut aller
l'l'expliquer.
- - Oui, Michel a raison de
sosouligner que ce qu'il manque
auaujourd'hui, c'est qu'il n'y a
plplus de pont entre la communaé
ananglophone et la majorité
frfrancophone et le gouvernemen.
AvAvant, il y avait Alliance
QuQuébec comme organisation qui
avavait beaucoup de crédibilité,
d'd'autres personnes. On n'a pls
tetellement de ces gens-là. Ce i
fafait qu'à ce moment-là, il pet
y y avoir beaucoup de malentends
etet d'anxiété pour rien. Je
pepersiste à penser que c'est ue
grgrosse erreur que Monsieur
LeLegault n'applique pas la loi
10101 oxygé parce que cette loia
ququand même manquer d'un moteu,
d'd'une énergie, d'un chocs
éléléments inquiétants, et Madae
AnAnglade l'a quand même dit
auaujourd'hui, la qualifier
d'd'extrémiste, c'est allé loin,
etet de nouveaux partis
ananglophones qui seront créés.t
c'c'est vrai que le parti pardo,
leles 2 parties prêchent pour le
bibilinguisme. Alors qu'avant,
c'c'était clair que c'était le
frfrançais qui devait être
prprédominant. L'application dea
loloi 101 oxygé, si Monsieur
LeLegault ne le fait pas, je pee
ququ'il va le regretter. - Maise
pepense qu'il ne le fera pas.
- - Moi je suis un rêveur.
- - Il ne le fera pas, anglais u
cécégep parce qu'il n'y a pas de
dodonnées probantes qui disent e
çaça va changer quelque chose. S